there's so many other things you could
be doing other than sitting around
sulking about someone who's not thinking
about you hey I'm Nate hi and today we
are going to talk about how we cope with
breakup last time I got my heart broken
was about two years ago okay yeah I
think the last time I had my heart
broken ha maybe about a year ago
I think you're always kind of recovering
from a breakup like you're never like um
perfectly fine it's okay I think
especially when you're spending so much
time with one person that becomes a part
of your life so just removing it it's
just there's gonna be you know a little
gap there I created my coping list
unfortunately through experience it just
kind of happens that way it comes with
age and it comes with experience and it
comes with just maturity then you figure
out like alright this is probably what I
need your whole world can be encompassed
around someone you have to remember what
you what your purpose was before you
were in a relationship and then focus on
that one of the first things that I do
is have a really good cry what do you do
kind of the same I don't know
oh like cry that much but like I still
am just very sad and I do sad things to
be one with your emotion yes in the dark
listening to the cure good chef in the
shadows wearing a cape my second point
is I think exercise is like the best
thing for you when you're sad or when
you're feeling something because it's
it's very therapeutic and meditate or
just like I'm just gonna focus on seeing
how far I can run or how much I can lift
or how many squats I can do
and that takes your mind out of the past
and puts it into the future and if you
have a good playlist going yeah it's
like I know for me it's Beyonce what is
yours secure my second point is again I
like to meditate on some of the things
that worked it didn't work so one thing
I'll do is if I find myself just sort of
ruminating over this person I will write
down the pros and the cons of a
relationship I have to remind myself
here the good times here the bad times
and then one of them is gonna outweigh
it and when you're like that it was
never gonna work because this whole
entire list says otherwise that has to
be very reassuring though when you're
like really sad and put it on paper and
then you see like oh that was mostly a
bad thing yeah yeah puts things into
perspective I like to just kind of make
sure that I'm not putting like
negativity in you know so I I limit my
drinking I limit my my binge eating and
my bad habits and I try and just kind of
get back to a place where I'm only doing
good things for myself yeah I like that
I'll say it's hard to get rid of cheese
and ice cream I mean all dairy it's like
that's all you want to eat when you
break up oh man okay this is very
important especially for our generation
you have to cut them off social media
out of sight out of mind and on social
media if you cannot control that you're
just gonna keep relapsing you're going
back to this person I think I think
social media definitely makes breakups
harder that's probably that's a really
smart point I also sometimes block their
friend
yeah they're also happy cuz when you
break up with someone you're also
breaking up with like that social circle
which sucks and I've had to explain this
like someone actually said to me what
did I do I'm like I love you but I just
I can't this person is tagged in all
your photos and I don't want to see it
I'm sorry I'm I'm healing right now I
can't
after I've kind of processed and kind of
gotten myself back to Zen I try and then
reconnect with my friends and family
when I first break up with somebody I
try really hard not to instantly go to
friends and family as I got a lot of
pain and I don't want to disperse that
pain that's fair it's like almost just
needing time to step back and grieve yes
I like to find that time because then
when I go see my friends and family I'm
not just like here's the only thing I
want to talk about today and that's it
my instinct when I break up with someone
is to go straight to my friends
interesting and straight to my family
because like that's your first round of
therapy essentially it's like to vent to
your friends and family this is also
sort of parallel to working out mm-hmm I
like to work out but also get like a
makeover Oh Mike I'll go get my hair
done get my nails done get wax get all
of the shenanigans like beautification
yeah like I'll just have beautification
day yeah because I I'm a firm believer
in like if you feel good if you look
good on the outside you'll start to feel
better on the inside and especially
features are like feeling real just yeah
you know putting on a red lip and a heel
let me tell you it works wonders I would
rather be crying on the streets with a
red lip and a heel than to be crying and
like a snuggie walking on the sidewalk
I'm just saying definitely I can't I
can't relate to the heels but yeah try
it last thing I like to do is I just I
just get over it it's done it's over I'm
moving on time has healed my wounds and
I'm fine wow that's easy for you
sometimes no but that's why it's really
important for me to do all those things
in advance is I feel all my things I
make sure that I'm taking care of myself
on the outside
making sure that I'm not burning any
bridges or missing out on any
connections and after I've done all of
those things
I know mechanically I should be fine so
it's time to start actually being fine I
like what you said you said you don't
want to waste any more time
yeah don't waste any more time that's a
good point because you know there's so
many other things you could be doing
other than sitting around sulking about
someone who's not thinking about you oh
god yes please
[Music]
I feel really good and I'm like I like
being single there are days where I'm
like I want a boyfriend oh Allah but I'm
content I'm happy like I'm happy myself
so like I think now I'm probably at a
better place where it could be in a
relationship because I'm like yeah this
one I think that's like the moment where
you know you're okay yeah is when you
you see that you're okay being single
yeah I'm okay you just had a break today
you did take care of yourself and be sad
it's okay you can be sad it's gonna be
okay
there's light at the end of the tunnel
go live your life
[Music]
[Music]
you